about pitching you know because it's i
just wanted to say one thing you know
like um i i was just the other day i was
trying to figure out you know what
exactly i do you know
um
you know i've done like 25 feature films
you know but um if you really analyze
what exactly i do like 9 to 10 whatever
i put in 12 hours a day all my life
99 of the time in spending in trying to
make a movie it's not actually making
the movie the actual time that you make
the movie when you're on a set making
the movie is like the vacation that's
like that's like that's like the
the vacation you you get for the hard
work that you have to put into it that's
so hard and you know and and and i think
that's sort of in a way it's the tragedy
of a lot of filmmakers that this is what
we have to do that you know there's very
few
filmmakers who actually are able to have
a different balance where they say i
spent 50 percent of my life actually
shooting and another 50 putting movies
together those are rare exceptions you
know and those are the gods that we look
up to whether it's woody allen or
spielberg or they actually seem to spend
50 percent of their energy and life and
work into actually making a movie but
for most of us
we spend 99 of our time trying to make a
movie you know trying to get the money
trying to do this to to convince people
to
you know and it's it's sort of sad
because at the end of your life you sort
of look man
you know all the movies that i would
have i was ready to make and wanted to
make and i only did a little fraction
because
it just took all this effort just to do
anything you know that's what i wanted
to say i don't know if it's worth
hearing but that's the reality and the
other thing you know
um you know i think now
you know i think a lot of filmmakers we
get the chance to actually make movies
because the tools have become so
inexpensive you know that we actually
all can sit down and make a movie and
but what is the really act of creation
you know and ultimately when i came to
the realization is to be an artist you
got to be really selfish unfortunately
it's it's a really selfish act you know
i mean we all say we're doing it because
it's for the world for this and that but
a lot of it is before ourselves and the
people around us really suffer you know
i mean they really do if you look at
most directors successful ones they've
gone through many broken marriages you
know their kids are like really messed
up they never got the attention you know
and i think you really have to be like a
god to be able to balance work with
with um your art you know and
and unfortunately you know when you are
young it's easier because you don't have
all these other things going on that you
can really just be totally selfish and
just do it for the art you know whether
you are a rock star or a writer or a
painter or musician or a dancer whatever
field you are in
but in ultimately in the end you know
you have to sort of figure out do i want
to be selfish
do it for myself or do i balance this
life
to the people around me and it's a
really tough call it's really tough
you